c'est quand même curieux ça il doit se
passer quelque chose d'important
casey mais recevant des idées bizarres
mais alors là le ton de sa lettre de sa
convocation mais tu as raison je les
c'est une véritable de convocation
tellement le ton en effet en tout cas
leur approche
nous n'allons pas tarder à savoir la
réponse je vous en prie vous vous étiez
là et peut vous devez être surpris de
nous voir billet comme ça julie est mort
figurez vous que nous venons de recevoir
une lettre de casimir nous ordonnons
devenir très propre et très bien habillé
pour une raison de la plus haute
importance savait pas pourquoi par
hasard on july 11 en trois soirs où vous
êtes drôlement élégant à pont sur vous
avez reçu la même lettre que moi vous
avez une lettre vous facteurs qu'est ce
que c'est drôle parce qu'il ya trop la
cftc c'est absurde mais je trouve ça
comique qu'un facteur à soi ville m
facteur à propos de l'être vous êtes au
courant de la raison de cette
convocation
pas du tout dit vous n'avez pas vu la
lettre officielle au mieux que je ne dis
pas le courrier d autres mois non le
facteur sais pas ce que je disais non
mais vous auriez plus par hasard voir un
tampon ou atteindre inhabituel
rien de tout ça le mystère demeure
entier mais très cher ami bush a un bon
jour c'est justement qu'elle élégant
merci ma très chère amie merci j'avoue
que ce costume va assez bien je pensais
qu'il conviendrait parfaitement à la
situation dite de chez disney vous savez
ce qui va se passer
non mais d'après la lettre ça m'a l'air
de la plus haute importance
mais peut-être nous nous recevoir la
visite d'un haut personnes
ma très chère amie voyons si un haut
personnage était en visite dans notre
île
j'en serais le premier averti j'entends
le retrait de casimir
bonjour mes amis bonjour puis je mens
jamais un jour je suis très content de
voir que vous avez tous répondu à mon
appel et nous vite de quoi il s'agit pas
encore boire il faut d'abord que je
vérifie si vous êtes tous et les gars
est propre sans suite en comble enfin
moi le personnage plus élégant de l'île
aux enfants de faire examiner par ce
ballon jamais à vous ou pas vous devrez
faire ce que je vous demande si vous
voulez participer à cet événement de la
plus haute importance fort bien examiner
moi bon invoque le papillon et de
travers votre costume et fripés vous
êtes mal coiffée montrez moi vos
oreilles mes oreilles pour voir si elles
sont prouvées jamais sûr c'est ça ou au
revoir
bon ça va
on soir oui une autre france on remet le
noeud papillon de monsieur du snap droit
julie roy françois s'il te plaît toi tu
est parfaite
merci il me semble que vos chaussures ne
brille pas beaucoup un tiens c'est vrai
tu as raison casimir je mets un petit
peu lésé suis avec mon mouchoir
mais que va-t-il se passer nous
attendons sa course est un bel appareil
salaire très compliqué tu seras t'en
servir - mais bien fou mettez-vous en
place y voilà je vais vous expliquer un
grand journal m'a demandé de faire une
photo de famille
les habitués du jardin et c'est très
impressionnant
est-ce pour sûr ça donne de temps mais
ne vous en faites pas chers amis je suis
là j'ai l'habitude de ce genre de choses
vous pensez bon alors si vous bien ça va
comme ça me saoule du smad un peu plus à
gauche françois plus adroit mais kelly
mur il ya quelque chose qui ne va pas
ben oui casimir tu ne peux pas en même
temps être derrière l'appareil photo est
ensuite être sur la photo sont casimir
il n'y a pas de famille de dix enfants
monsieur du snsa pour ceux ci mes amis
grâce à cet appareil super perfectionner
au tournant cette manivelle j'ai juste
le temps de venir me placer devant
l'appareil
alors attention peu serré vous bien
souriez un peu plus le soliste club ça
va c'est parfait attention au tard on
recommence
sarko mais c'est pas grave on aime bien
ça ne bougeait plus oui on y va
attention up parfait et bien là c'est
pas pour cette fois l'apéro c'est bien
attention
voilà cette fois la photo sera bonne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ne devrait plus tarder et pavan et
les facteurs pour développer et tirer
une photo il faut du temps surtout pour
un journal il faut qu'elle soit
développée avec beaucoup d'attention à
je sens que dessus je vais avoir un chip
très bien dans le journal sur la photo
casimir
ouais et alors